hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde wir spielen heute den
hirsch simulator
zuallererst müssen wir uns jedoch
unseren charakter erstellen das hier
sind bisher wir wir kriegen jetzt
einfach mal aufs gesicht
wir können jetzt hier unfassbar viele
sachen
als hat das ist ja krasser als bei
das ist ja größer als bei sims ja leute
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich hab jetzt
keine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin 2 30 jahre alt und komme aus
marokko
barocco
hinsichtlich der haare können wir ihnen
einfach mal einen kompletten afro würde
ich sagen hut kriegt dann natürlich auch
noch aber dann sieht man die haare nicht
mehr wirklich auf jeden fall ein
bauarbeiter hut dann kriegt dann auch
airports rhein ein shirt kriegt dann
natürlich auch noch als hose kriegt eine
grüne schuhe nehmen wir diese frischen
braunen und im bad kriegt er natürlich
auch so wie ich
habe übrigens eine brille
neuerdings weil ich eine
hornhautverkrümmung habe und das hört
sich an als 66
augenfarbe grün ich habe auch grüne
augenscheinlich solcher aber egal
körperform machen wir mal so und da
kommen lassen fertig
da kommt noch james und
das
hobby durch stellt damit jetzt um
gefährdung getötet wird
james
man lernt
das spiel geht los damit dass wir
sterben wir lassen uns mal wieder
beleben und sind jetzt im
juni dass ich mich wieder hier laufen
sieht aus wie eine stadt wir sind wieder
belebt worden als hirsch weil wir ein
reh vor dem tod bewahrt haben und jetzt
das tutorial
irgendwie
erinnert mich das sehr stark an den gott
simulator die sache ist nur dass wir
hier gerade das tutorial spielen und man
das eigentlich mit dem controller
spielen muss ich habe allerdings
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich würde ganz leicht auf wen wir
lassen das man mit dem auto und
konzentrieren uns jetzt auf unsere
mitmenschen bzw mit tiere die hier auch
sein hallo erfährt wie es bei dir hast
du bock mich mal zu reiten oder
[Musik]
als ich mir heute diese brille gekauft
habe beim optiker hier nebenan da hat er
mich gefragt was machen sie denn
beruflich wegen ob ich vom pc sitzt oder
er nicht gerne comics ja ich mache so
youtube-videos ok gucke ich mir dann
machen wir heißen sie denn da
die begrüßen den händen kann
für so eine scheiße brauchte ich die
brille ich habe keine ahnung was ich
jetzt perfekt eingepackt habe ich auch
da vorne ich kann hier auf jeden fall
jetzt rumreiten
[Musik]
nabu ist bringt nichts wenn du hub sei
dann nämlich rein rechtlich muss
springen lernen das habe ich jetzt
gemacht sprinten wir können auch
ich glaube aber das geht nicht auf dem
pferd deswegen steige ich erst mal ganz
kurz ab und jetzt wenn ich so
ich frag mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
perfect day gab
danke dir ist ja nicht so dass ich da
meine kamera distanz ausrichten wollte
und da hinten hat einfach ein roller
ohne fahrer alles klar ich freue mich
auf jeden fall gar nichts mehr wir
gucken jetzt einfach nicht tot
hallo also okay
da hinten ist immer noch unser auto was
wir da gerade perfekt gepackt wir vorn
haben polizisten vielleicht kann er uns
ja sagen was wir falsch gemacht haben
sagt hallo
ist das da oben ein fisch
[Musik]
leute
das ist das mit abstand
verstörendste spiel was ich je gespielt
habe ich frag trotzdem jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz den polizisten was hier abgeht
fälschlichen tue ich
habe ihn vorher schlicht
und der kann auch tanzen
[Musik]
ich würde allerdings sagen dass ich sehe
mich jetzt hier nochmal ganz
ich hab nichts gedrückt
ist dieser typ der er zwei hier schlecht
ist mein buddy
ich dachte ich wenn mein bodyguard und
der wird alle autos die box nicht zu
nahe kommen ich laufe weiter verfolgte
mich jetzt
egal wo dagegen läuft es geht kaputt
jetzt ist er wieder ganz normale
menschen sind wir los geworden hier
vorher hat er allerdings trotzdem ein
bad der verwüstung angerichtet ich muss
noch lernen wie man sprintet ich weiß
nicht wie das geht es geht wieder auf
alten auf störungen noch auf schimpfte
machen
ich habe sprinten gelernt
diese komische rolle die ich
ist das nur über die man
freunde ich habe viel zu viele fragen
nach vorne fliegt ein elefant wieder
durch die gegend von daher würde ich an
dieser stelle das heutige video jetzt
auch beenden wenn ihr einen zweiten teil
von dir simulator mit luca sehen wollt
von den verstörendsten spiel was ich
hier gesehen habe dann lasst den daumen
hoch unter dem video abonnieren kann
klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollt ich brauche
jetzt erstmal therapeuten